buongiorno a tutti grazie
dell'accoglienza e grazie
all'organizzazione che mi ha voluto qui
oggi su questo palco grazie grazie
davvero
dunque voglio usare questi minuti
concessi per parlarvi di un paio di
ragionamenti che ho fatto nel corso
della mia vita e che mi hanno portato a
essere qui su questo palco e che lo
rende in realtà ancora più incredibile e
voglio usare una metafora quella dei
binari del treno
queste due grossi travi d'acciaio sopra
i quali viaggi e un treno e che non può
davvero realtà cambiare direzione perché
quella è lui tira dritto e va avanti il
viaggio tranquillo e si è deciso di
portare questo discorso oggi è perché
penso che nella mia vita varie
coincidenze mi hanno portato a farmi
delle domande davvero molto importanti
ea trovare delle risposte che voglio
condividere con voi e che penso siano
davvero importanti in questi tempi
questo tipo di riflessioni e non penso
davvero di voler insomma non dovete fare
per far sei mesi step di vita per
chiedervi queste cose quindi oggi lo
farò io io sono roberto e sono una
persona fuori dai binari
solo introverso con un leggero deficit
dell'attenzione con i quali è combattuta
un po però lo sto un po rigirando mio
favore
come professione la mia vita
professionale gira intorno all'arte e
alle dirette sul famoso sito di
streaming viola è la mia vita
professionale però non è stata per
niente semplice perché sono stata
abolita durante tutta l'adolescenza
facevo qualcosa per meritarmelo no
semplicemente non rientravo negli
standard sociali del tempo non avevo
l'aspetto giusto che è una colpa che
molti adolescenti si portano dietro
negli anni non avevo le passioni giuste
a me piacevano musica particolare i
cartoni animati e non avevo nemmeno il
carattere giusto
questa però nella sfortuna si rivela una
grande fortuna perché in realtà
attraverso questo mio essere così mi
sono stati preclusi davvero tanti i
binari sociali i primi quelli su cui
molte persone viaggiano all'inizio non
posso per esempio citare la andare a
studiare insieme è il condividere le
prime ansie le prime relazioni che sono
state tutte cose precluse precluse mi
all'inizio della mia vita fuori dal
nucleo famigliare di casa che però nella
sfortuna appunto si sono rivelate una
grande fortuna perché mi hanno permesso
di farmi alcune domande davvero
importanti e di queste domande strappare
il contesto è valorizzare veramente
quello che stavo facendo in quel momento
domande tipo ma se io prendo questo voto
no che è alto e basso questo voto ha un
valore e questa scala dei valori chi chi
me la valuta ai professori ma i
professori interessa che io sia felice
oppure triste e per quanto riguarda i
miei compagni invece nel senso che cos'è
che ha il valore il numero sulla
bilancia è il mio aspetto quindi sono i
miei le mie passioni quindi quindi se
quel numero cambia allora è lì che io
acquisisco del valore
sto cercando di capire ragazzi non
fatemi capire perché mi sento persa e mi
sembra che tutti voi stiate andando
avanti sui vostri binari e andate dritti
e io sono fermo in stazione e non
capisco che devo fare
tutto questo ha avuto importanza in un
fino a un giorno specifico del liceo
l'ultimo quando ne sono uscita perché ho
capito che effettivamente quella
maschera di valori aveva importanza solo
nel retaggio scolastico e che fuori era
tutto diverso avevo molto più spazio di
manovra e per un po riassumere i miei
anni universitari un po dopo
ho iniziato a fare dell'arte ho
disegnato per me ho iniziato a ricevere
le prime richieste dagli altri il
problema è che le domande non si
fermavano ormai avevo iniziato questo
processo di domande quindi iniziato a
chiedermi ma quindi adesso io ho un
valore se disegno quindi effettivamente
più disegno è più o i like su facebook
che era la valuta al tempo che insomma
era un po esplosa e più faccio queste
cose più quindi o valore però il deficit
dell'attenzione mi porta a voler anche
aggiungere altro perché effettivamente
non mi va di avere un valore solo se
passo 12 13 ore su un disegno voglio
fare qualcosa anche nel frattempo penso
di avere qualcosa da dire quindi avere
un valore anche se ci sarà una faccia
dietro e se voglio condividere o una
passione per le chiacchiere quindi
voglio aggiungere anche questo posso
avere anche valori in questo ci siamo
fermati di disegni e alla fine l'ho
fatto mi sono messa oltre a fare di
disegni anche ad avere un volto
sull'internet e ho iniziato a fare
qualche diretto che poi si sono
trasformate in tre ore al giorno negli
ultimi cinque anni quindi qualcosa mi è
davvero piaciuto e qualcosa ha
funzionato e quindi adesso è tutto a
posto adesso posso guadagnare posso
andare a vivere da sola posso rendere
perché usa la famiglia e dire guarda
mamma adesso ho un affitto però poi ci
sarà la casa da comprare mi mi faccio
muto poi la macchina e la macchina
alcune della macchina ok sì sì poi poi
mi raccomando il partner fisso i figli i
figli prima dei trent'anni perché sennò
poi un pò strano e poi devo ragionare un
po per continuare insomma fare del
lavoro e poi arrivare alla pensione
però vedo un po strano nel senso io
perché ho già questo piano di vita non
so neanche cosa mi piacerà quando avrò
tra 30 anni oppure dopo
perché questi sono i binari o finalmente
ci sono arrivati sono qui davanti a me
finalmente ho capito dove stavano
andando gli altri io non avevo ancora
avuto modo di scorgere queste cose ho
capito e quelli step che devo percorrere
lo so mi sento parte di questa cosa che
però mi sembra un po limitante nel senso
per me per carità e non è qualcosa che
deve avere per forza che fare con tutti
il problema nasce quando questi step
precedentemente citati vengono messi
come metro di giudizio per farci sentire
inadeguati una scala dove si pentì da
una parte li fai sei di successo e
invece se prendi dall'altra parte sin
fallito certo tra le tante cose per cui
possiamo essere giudicati questo è un
bel pò stellone
peccato che anche volendolo fare questi
binari non è che ci sono davvero nel
senso non posso più dire ciao mamma ho
24 anni o la laurea
adesso faccio una lavoro piccolino una
gavetta però per poco è perché fra
pochissimo potrò fare il lavoro dei miei
sogni per cui ho sempre studiato per cui
mi sono sbattuto e insomma sai mi dici
sempre che che alla tua età
insomma quando i tu avevi la mia età mi
avevi partorito noi quindi e quindi ti
sentiresti un po di aver sbagliato
qualcosa se non facessi lo stesso
peccato che quando i miei genitori
avevano la niente mi avevano partorito
non si erano mai registrati i 48 gradi a
siracusa
quindi forse le priorità stanno un po
cambiando diciamo negli ultimi anni e
quando questo a questa cosa mi viene un
po da ragionare per immagini io lavoro
per immagini e quindi mi viene in mente
questa grande figura con questo grande
libro né davanti che che universalmente
a tutti quanti perché tutti sappiamo che
è quello il modo di farlo fa il check
qualità e quindi ci dice ok
l'università ce l'hai fatto l'università
è perché se no qua è brutto mi
raccomando poi il lavoro i figli i figli
prima dei 30 anni che non vuoi fare un
figlio prima dei trent'anni che poi alle
cene su una strana e se ti fanno una
domanda che risponde che non li vuoi
fare e non puoi fare questo rispetto
alla tua famiglia che ti ha cresciuto mi
raccomando ttt e poi si segna le righe
no e me la risolve realtà un po easy
perché mi vien in mente che è un po
tutto un gioco di ruolo fra di noi non
c'è un check qualità e non è che esiste
universalmente questa cosa però ce la
siamo un po creata diciamo questi questi
binari
non ci sono e so che magari ci si può
sentire spaesati per chi
invece sceglie se l'era predisposti e
vorrebbe farli però penso che sia
proprio qui il momento in cui noi
puntiamo i piedi e iniziamo a farci
altre domande e non per forza applicare
addosso a noi un contesto che viene
universalmente applicato a tutti ci fa
sentire inadeguati penso che sia adesso
il momento in cui noi distruggiamo i
luoghi comuni
possiamo possiamo finalmente distruggere
quel concetto che ci siamo portati che
azzurro maschietto rosa femminuccia
possiamo decidere se credere in che fede
credere
possiamo addirittura scoprire la nostra
sessualità confrontandoci quel potere
dell'internet con delle persone che alla
fine vivono ai nostri stessi disagi e
non dobbiamo per forza sentirci
sbagliati e inadeguati perché non siamo
parte di questi binari
e qualcosa tra l'altro in cui io credo
tantissimo e qui finora ho fatto un
discorso un po generale però vorrei
davvero in questo momento riferirmi a i
millennials ea che sono la generazione
80 94 e alla generazione z che invece
classe 95 2010 e devi questo
siete degli eroi non so se ve l'hanno
mai detto o hanno solo dato per scontato
che nella vostra più tenera età
affrontaste due crisi economiche con in
mezzo un po di pandemia globale che
insomma ci ha lasciato senza scuola
senza lavoro insomma ci guardano tutti
un po come se fosse semplice perché
potevamo affondare in questo senso di
solitudine davanti a delle serie tv
tutto il giorno finché la pandemia non
sarebbe finita
e allora ve lo dico io siamo
inaffondabili e mi prendo questo potere
questo merito e ve lo riconosco col
potere conferitomi da me stesso e
chissenefrega se gli altri non sta bene
perché i notai questo su cui insisto
molto sulle dirette precedentemente
citate
sul valore e sugli standard che ognuno
di noi si deve dare da solo ognuno di
noi deve costruirsi i propri binari e
deve farsi le sue domande perché con le
sue nuove risposte può viaggiare più
tranquillo su qualcosa che che forse è
più adatto al suo stile di vita e sa
qualcosa che insomma dopo far sentire
bene gli può far capire perché io anche
oggi mi sto sbagliando e sto andando
avanti con la mia vita e domani e che
cosa che mi fa felice perché non credo
che arrivare esausto a casa il dry armi
solo sul divano sia la felicità è solo
che sono esausto sono esausto e la vita
fa troppo rumore io non riesco a
fermarmi non riesco a capire qual è
davvero il senso di tutto quanto e
quindi mi devo fermare e farmi delle
domande e trovare risposte
però messa così sembra un po una all
utopia tutto bello insomma ci fermiamo
prendiamo le facciamo le nostre domande
quindi per amor di consapevolezza in
realtà devo inserire un po altri punti
per un quadro generale della situazione
perché comunque dovremo infilarci in un
sistema che ci fa fare soldi dobbiamo
sopravvivere e mi raccomando che sia un
lavoro statale perché sennò siamo pigri
e non abbiamo voglia di lavorare che
insomma non c'è molto spazio per le
nostre spiegazioni e così punto siamo
pigri siamo giovani abbiamo di far
niente e
parlo per i genitori dico a voi genitori
dico che provo a mettermi in realtà nei
vostri panni e dire che lo capisco
volete solo un futuro migliore per noi
però se non c'è un punto d'incontro fra
il vostro contesto e i vostri tempi ai
nostri tempi ci sarà uno standard e
forse irraggiungibile per quelli che su
quello che adesso il nostro presente e
si generano incomprensioni e distacco e
non deve essere per forza così bisogna
solo capirsi e ascoltarsi capire come
noi possiamo affrontare queste cose
nuove che tu alla tua italgest di
facendo però adesso il mio turno e devo
capire come farlo
c'è anche un'altra categoria di persone
che sono quelle che semplicemente non
avranno voglia di vedervi prende le cose
che mi fanno felici delle cose
precedentemente citate la sessualità la
fede e il lavoro e a queste persone dico
va bene così capirete capitano però è il
momento di decidere per noi stessi
verremo verremo costantemente messi
sulla strada dell insicurezza di questo
ne sono sicura perché ancora adesso mi
sono fatta tante domande e vivo ancora
dei dubbi durante la mia età 27 anni
però
penso che queste nuove risposte saranno
veramente
l'inizio di un mondo che migliora perché
se sono qui su questo palco a fare
questo discorso è perché parlo anche per
quelle persone che insomma un po hanno
vissuto anche quello che ho vissuto io
adolescenza bruttina
non riesco a capire cosa inventarmi per
arrivare a fine mese poi in partita iva
lascia fare e poi insomma ci sono anche
il lavoro e le cose non riesco a capire
come essere soddisfatto pienamente tra
la vita e felice
quindi in realtà siccome dalla vita mi
sono presa tanto adesso voglio ridare
indietro e oggi dedico questo discorso e
fare un po le veci dell'intera categoria
anche si sente un po come me
l'obiettivo di oggi non era lasciarvi
con delle risposte ma perché io so ma ho
avuto il tempo per insomma trovare le
mie però vorrei lasciarvi con tante
nuove domande perché penso veramente che
con queste nuove risposte
vi sarete ripresi il tempo che questa
vita che frenetica corre su dei binari
vi sta togliendo perché il tempo per se
stessi per scoprire se stessi non
produce soldi e quindi a nessuno
interessa lasciarvelo e perciò dobbiamo
prenderci o da soli e io farò il tifo
per voi grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]